[Music]
I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish today's
topic may be the ultimate crowd favorite
we're talking all about pasta we head to
Brooklyn to meet the chef behind two of
the most coveted Italian restaurants in
the tri-state area and to Italy for the
inside look at how one popular pasta and
broth creation is made but first we head
to a Michelin starred restaurant in
Manhattan's Flatiron District where one
Chef is serving up Cuisine based on the
Emilia romagna region of Italy
chef
Steffen other new
Julian restaurant
we don't take ourselves very serious but
we take you know what we do very serious
and pasta being really important for us
all homemade everything yep
at resdora which Loosely translates to
Nona or grandmother yeah
he's brought a piece of them and Italy
to New York
this is one of those raccoons that I
made with the known as Austria juice
team many times like Laura marindian
it's one of those things that
you just want to kind of sit and think
about it right no I want to eat more no
I don't want to no question I want
anymore all right the taliolini served
with Ragu modinese is one of around two
dozen pastas on the resdora menu
with seki leading diners on a
gastronomic journey through the Amelia
romagna region of Italy you need to grab
a Yoko Frito because these are still
piping hot but you have Mortadella there
do I just take a bite of this yeah I
mean here's what I do it's gonna be
messy it's hot but you want to fold it
over like this and then and like a nice
little pot of Brava
that's good I was lucky enough to get a
private tour a lot of the dishes are
just based on like memories that I have
either growing up going to Italia and or
working there like these black truffle
Lobster gerasole we used to go to Remini
and we used to take the train there and
you see sunflowers on the way and what
would you eat you would eat seafood
right it literally is that's a little
Sunfish little sunflower so the idea is
you have that black truffle with the
Beautiful Love certain little bit of
lobster stock to make the sauce I love
that it's a little work of art too
there was also that wovo raviolo di Nino
burguesse a tribute to the chef who made
the original dish famous in the region
this seasonal variation is topped with
white truffle and brown butter filled
with ricotta and egg yolk like a farm
fresh egg inside and it's dark orange
like we have the best eggs you can get
your hands on you have worked tirelessly
to get these eggs eight nine months to
figure out how to get the right eggs
where we actually get them from the
south now believe it or not from
Arkansas
guys put it order fire yeah seki calls
the gramina gialloe Verde the sleeper
served with slow braised sausage Ragu in
Bianco far more decadent is resdora's
contemporary version of Angelini filled
with 24 month old prosciutto
Mortadella and pork shoulder topped with
parmigiano sauce with the signature
cheese also aged for two years and for
us finished with a century-old
balsamico well that balsamic
it just brings out flavor I'm gonna give
you another one because you're gonna ask
me for another one no I'm just going to
reach over and take it that works too
and then there's the one dish seki says
he can never take off the menu Grandma
walking through forest in Amelia based
off Sundays spent eating at the homes of
local nonas it's cappelletti pasta with
braised and sauteed leeks parmigiano and
a porcini mushroom base this knowing
that we see we all in her backyard and
find Lake porcini and she would roast
porcini bracelets and then we'd make
this capaletti's based off the Romania
region in Romania those are you know
memories he put together they call how
do you find a way to incorporate until
the story how do you make that story
into a pasta has she ever had this pasta
I'm trying to get her to come over
come over can you tell can you like no
no please come over
how much fun is it for you
to create these taste memories
amazing right I mean your eyes just said
it if you're gonna do this as a job then
then you should probably just be all in
if not then why do it Nick you got a
second course together yeah seki grew up
in Texas one of three kids born to
Immigrant parents including an Italian
father while they ran a restaurant and
sent him back to Italy each summer seki
says he didn't always see food as his
calling my parents had me working really
early I would be like basketball
football practice or baseball or
whatever and then like I would have to
go right to work I could never finish
practice and like that makes you bitter
I mean I'm gonna be honest and like you
don't see that back then but now I I
can't think my parents enough he says it
all changed when he graduated high
school enrolled in The Culinary
Institute of America and moved to New
York City I interned externed in the
city here cooking and that's when I when
I was finally around places where people
were like really taking it serious is
when I got fired up and then
I was eating around a lot and I still
never tasted the food that I'd eat in
Italians for so long so that's where he
headed living in Modena for the next
three years learning his craft from both
nonas and Masters you should pay homage
to these people that have been doing it
for so long and so well and respect it
you should learn how the basics are done
we talk about contemporary pasta or a
classic pasta gramina talulini I knew
they need to an extent these are the
classics right and so learn how the
classics are done and then you can be
contemporary and find ways to like work
speaking of that jira Soleil Chef was
kind enough to give me a quick lesson in
creating the restora favorite see where
there's an edge pinch and well I didn't
exactly show his promise mine's not
looking as pretty as yours how many
points
takes an obvious pride in the Traditions
he learned
lots of Beauty look at that and
continues to pass on be it by touch or
taste
life is short when you find out what you
want to do start becoming obsessed with
it things become pretty cool is that
where you are right now I hope yeah I
mean I'm obsessed and pretty cool yeah
yeah yeah Dana it's the best business
your job is to make people happy every
day
putting food in people's mouths where
people were like oh my God like you're
out of the kitchen and you're in the
dining room and you're just watching
like customers talk to each other and
then even say word and they just shake
their head and smile that's all you need
right that's our job is to make people
happy I mean it's crazy but that's cool
it's incredibly cool
up next A Taste of tortellini in Italy
[Music]
Italy is home to All Things pasta from
unique shapes to delectable fillings and
even the flavorful sauces we put on top
Seth don't takes us to Florence and
bologna where he learns how to perfect
the making of a classic tortellini
it's not from a terrine but it's good
I'm Seth Doan in Italy sampling
tortellini embrodo that's broth in
Italian it's traditionally a comfort
food for the holidays but it's welcome
in any season
if I have to take one dish to a desert
island for the rest of my life this
would be it that's saying something for
Rolando beramendi a chef and cookbook
author did you put tortellini brodo in
your book no I didn't because it's so
complicated that I think it would be
very difficult to translate
incredible even he leaves it to the
experts that means for a good 30 years
he's come to Trattoria Camilo a four
generation Family Restaurant in Florence
where they make it look simple as
Leonardo da Vinci said Simplicity is the
ultimate art of sophistication
first owner Kiara masiero gets the pasta
or swole up as thin as possible then
there's the filling and the flourish and
we make the triangle close at the point
this one comes down
she's made a few tortellini in her time
just how many
millions and then you've got the filling
here her recipe for the filling ground
pork and turkey Mortadella prosciutto
and parmesan cheese was her father's he
was from bologna which lays claim to
this pasta
and where it fills stomachs store fronts
and is taking on almost mythical status
one of the Tall Tales of tortellini is
that an Innkeeper spied on Venus the
goddess of love through a keyhole and
then created a pasta in the shape of her
navel today the pasta itself is
lustworthy and aficionados say there's
only one way to truly appreciate it you
worked so hard to develop this exfolia
with the eggs and that filling the only
way that you exalt all those flavors
at Bologna's Paulo atti and Sons the
skilled hands of erigrandi can turn out
350 tortellini an hour
you don't want to taste the pasta you
want to taste the filling The Bolognese
are religious about their tortellini
owner Francesco bonaga told us they had
some of theirs hand delivered to Pope
Francis
here he said you can see the bishop
explaining to Pope Francis that
tortellini must be cooked in broth
yes he added with great attention the
tortellini is going to absorb all the
beautiful succulents of their broth
Rolando beramendi explained the broth
vegetables and Hearty cuts of beef all
strained before serving is essential to
the balance of this specialty what's
more important in this equation the
tortellini or the broth
that's a tough question it's almost like
to be or not to be right this comforting
dish is so simple yet complex that some
believe the central ingredient deserves
to be celebrated as a hero
there are several Italian restaurants in
the New York City area serving up fine
pastas but Chef Missy Robbins two
restaurants Lilia and Missy are often at
the top of pasta lovers lists the
legendary Chef showed our Jeff glor how
she makes her decadent dishes
we really set out to to make something
that would feel Timeless Missy Robbins
grew up an ocean away from the focus of
her book pasta the spirit and craft of
Italy's greatest food a Jewish girl
raised in a kosher household in
Connecticut
she took a transformational trip to
Italy in her 20s after serving as an
executive chef in Chicago in New York
she opened her first restaurant Lilia in
Brooklyn in 2016. that was followed two
years later by Missy at both spots do
turns into art you list 45 different
pasta shapes in the book and that if I'm
understanding this correctly is just
scratching the surface totally I mean I
I there are thousands of pasta shapes
and also they get intertwined with
different names I mean there are 400
things that are called ravioli alone
there's 400 things you know my tortelli
looks totally different than my
neighbor's tortelli one of the big
things you talk about in the book
everybody I think knows that making
fresh pasta can be challenging yes and
laborious cooking pasta is challenging
as well oh yeah if done the right way
yes you know there's not just like
boiling the pasta it's like how is your
water salted is it salted enough never
ever put oil in your water please don't
ever put oil on your water because
you'll never be able to get to the next
point which is marriage and the marriage
ceremony which is really kind of it so
you always want to finish your pasta in
the sauce and don't drain the water
never drain the water why so when you
cook pasta in water some of that starch
comes out and that becomes part of of
the sauce pasta water is key it's an
ingredient
just one of the many lessons Robin
shares from a career and life that in
the past several years has seen both her
greatest triumphs and her biggest
challenges
she was diagnosed with breast cancer in
2017. now recovered she also totally
changed her lifestyle in her 40s you've
talked openly you've written about this
you've talked about it about your
struggles with weights yeah I I was
40 plus pounds more than I am today and
I was unhealthy like I wasn't breathing
correctly I I just didn't feel good and
it's not healthy and I it's really like
no other kind of addictive behavior my
advice has always been food ironically I
had really bad sort of tasting habits in
the kitchen her new diet does include
yes less pasta which doesn't mean dish
segments can't be occasional Splurge
opportunities
grilled broccoli sharp provolone garlic
bread crumbs that was followed by beans
and grilled escarole leeks with anchovy
vinaigrettes parsley and pistachio and
artichokes braised and grilled topped
with mint salsa verde he said I love
artichokes when I was a kid
so these are first cooked in olive oil
and wine and a lot of aromatics and then
they're grilled when you order them
the sauce is amazing
and the men so fresh
you're gonna eat every single thing why
not that's amazing do you want a little
plate no I want you to which was good
because we were just getting started
next was whipped ricotta on grilled
sourdough served with roasted mushrooms
preserved in olive oil this looks like
it could change your life it doesn't
matter what I put with it people are not
ordering it because of the vegetable
they're ordering it because of that 100
and it's like the most Instagram dish
I've ever seen
wow moving on to Pasta we have tortelli
this is a spinach and mascarpone filled
pasta finished with brown butter there
was also meze rigatoni with her
signature 30 clove sauce
chickpea peppardelli with rosemary
parmesan and lemon
bucatini with induya and gnocchi Sardi
or malaritus with a fennel saffron and
pork sausage sauce
and this is another pasta shape though
that we talked about we're like yeah
similar to other ones yeah each one of
those is done by hand on a little board
every single one each one of these each
that is not done by a machine that is
done by a human
their work is worth wow wow that smile I
think I just found your favorite
I think that is my favorite my favorite
too well you won't find it listed on the
menu the only entree available at Missy
is besteca Fiorentina it's marinated in
garlic and rosemary and finished with
olive oil lemon and fennel pollen
all that was followed by a presentation
of seven different kinds of gelato one
featuring olive oil olive oil ice cream
yes
we also had chocolate chocolate chip
pistachio espresso Fior de latte and
hazelnuts though for me it was all about
the mint chocolate chip
oh wow
yeah fresh mint oh my gosh
this is novel and really cool but that's
my favorite all right we'll keep going
we did our Feast was accompanied by a
cocktail that's become one of Robin's
specialties
what is this this is the Missy Spritz
this is the Missy Spritz yes
to Pasta thank you so much for having me
are you going to try the steak oh yeah
after the break we take a closer look at
the plethora of pasta shapes this is the
dish
whether you like penne or rigatoni
linguine or fettuccine there is truly a
pasta shape for everyone Faith saley
shows us the possibilities are endless
in a segment first scene on CBS Sunday
Morning
pasta
delicious ubiquitous
groovy
in the world of pasta it's a kind of a
mirror world it's the other side of the
the Looking Glass everything is
absolutely groovy
[Music]
this one is called capelletti little
hats architect Georges legandre finds
pasta's curves a delicious departure
from the right angles of the everyday
world if you compare to the built
environment everything's squarish more
or less you know the tables the chairs
the buildings he says one of life's
simplest Foods is far more complex than
most of us realize I found that a lot of
the shapes have amazingly beautiful
diagrams you might call them which might
inspire you to designing say your
spiraling Museum ramp which is beautiful
in a way as a throttle very well
designed to accommodate sources because
it's tubular the genre spent two years
collecting and organizing every type of
pasta he could find 92 different shapes
and captured them all in a book called
pasta by Design
we use mathematics to design buildings
you know we've done a bridge we've done
artwork and now we've done pasta each
for all these sort of lovingly designed
using computer programs he describes the
design and shape of pastas you might
have heard of like say spaghetti to
those you certainly haven't
take the fisar Monique named after the
Italian word for accordion
or the stratza pretty Italian for priest
Strangler
it's really just trigonometry one of the
crazy things about this project
um mathematically speaking is that
everything is done with two functions
for the genre the mathematical functions
sine and cosine cook up a pretty
interesting recipe in terms of design
I would say the invisible mathematics of
pasta are absolutely staggering because
they deal with so Dynamic things that we
can't even fathom
airflows pressure temperature I mean
these are things that are very very
abstract
and if all of this seems a little Rich
the design of pasta really does matter
says Jacob Kennedy London chef and
author of the geometry of pasta does a
different shape of pasta have a
different taste different shapes of
pasta will interact differently but in
particular with their sauce and they
will give you a different experience
tortellini for example a lovely in a
creamy sauce that can coat them they put
a lot of nooks and crannies for the
source to fill and you can really feel
the shape with your tongue I know is
you're eating it
tortellini Legend has it was modeled
after a certain anatomical feature of
one of the most famous women of the
Italian Renaissance Lucrezia Borgia
the tail is Abuja stops overnight for a
romantic Christina in an inn and The
Innkeeper was a bit besotted with her
and he went up to Snoop at her room when
he looked through the through the
keyhole and all he could see was a was
her navel so he ran downstairs
and made a pasta in its shapes fantastic
[Music]
I'm Yours
your satini
take a moment to digest its design
a miracle of Simplicity and complexity
that happens every day
[Music]
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Dana Jacobson
we'll see you next time for another
helping of the dish